this morning the Kremlin says there is
no significant evidence that Russia
meddled in the election the comments
come as we learn more about Russia's
so-called troll Factory that generated
fake social media post the special
Council says they were intended to
undermine Hillary Clinton while
supporting her opponents including
Donald Trump Elizabeth Palmer is outside
the building in st. Peterburg st.
Petersburg rather thought to be the
center of the Russian influence
operation Elizabeth good morning good
morning this rather ordinary looking
office building behind me was the
headquarters of the troll factories II
by now infamous internet research agency
named in the indictment which also says
it was controlled by a Kremlin insider
and oligarch called yevgeniy pretty
goshen he made his money in the
restaurant business that's him serving
George W Bush during a state visit with
President Vladimir Putin here in st.
Petersburg in 2002 several young
activists surreptitiously filmed video
inside the internet research agency and
we spoke to one of them Ludmila Savage
she says she was shocked by the scale of
the operation as for the operation that
targeted the u.s. she says not only the
13 people named in the indictment should
be prosecuted but so should hundreds of
others who were involved the indictment
says that in the run-up to the u.s.
election the internet research agency
was working round-the-clock employing
hundreds of people and spending more
than a million dollars a month Nora all
right Elizabeth Palmer in st. Petersburg
thank you